so three balls juggling Workshop
foundations of patterns and two men two
men less
three ball Cascade we have four types of
catches the normal as shown here the
claw
the penguin
and the back of the hand
next you have body throws
a different category still all in
Cascade under the leg
uh behind the back
shoulder throw
over the head juggling
and
using the body on the head
still all within a three ball Cascade
next we move on to the standards
patterns that most strugglers learned
Cascade yeah
reverse Cascade
tennis I'm all over the top
half shower
same side over the top
full shower or the windmill
still 333 Mills mess
classic three throws in each Direction
one two three
the Box
yes
you have
columns each bar stays in its own column
so the basis for one up to it
then you have side swaps each throw is
assigned a number based on how many
balls you're juggling with three balls
it's called three three three three with
four it's a four all the evens stay on
the same side all the odds cross goes on
and up five and so forth if the sum of
the numbers is divisible by the amount
of balls you're juggling you'll have a
working pattern three three three equals
nine it's nine divided by three is a
whole number we're good to go four four
one same principles up up over
five three one
up over
four three two a two is a little hole
this little Gap where you can do
yeah
yes but it's all based on this
this
jacket
that's side swap in a nutshell there's
millions of patterns to do there then we
have active twos so uh all the things to
do with that Gap off the body
first is what I would learn just touch
it then move it and you can throw it
under the arm
over the arm
so on and so forth
all of these different categories can be
mixed together for example four four one
let's take that one around the body yay
penguin
mixing catches and body throws together
gives you an infinite variation with
patterns and eventually people blend it
all together they hate whatever you want
that was Eli March Master wrongs Prop
Shop Retreat 1998. woo